so look if you're in the business of
getting people's attention meaning
you're on camera you're writing you're
talking you're speaking you're selling
if that's your business the one kiss of
death for you
is to be boring you cannot be
boring anything but be boring where did
this topic come from yesterday i'm doing
my private monthly webinar with 75
entrepreneurs from around the world
and they asked me questions we go for 90
minutes one of the guys is talking about
starting his own podcast
starting his own youtube channel while
he's talking about this i start asking
him
crazy questions i said so tell me what
is the craziest opinion you have
what are your thoughts about this what
are your thoughts about that he gives
he's giving me stuff well i'm like yeah
maybe okay that's interesting and i'm
listening to him i said look
if you're trying to make it on tv
youtube if you're trying to make it on
the screen
if you're trying to make it on writing
if you're trying to make it on audio you
cannot be boring
think about personalities out there by
the way i'll explain the difference
between running a company
that is repetitively boring same system
and i'll talk about personality
if you think about it jeff bezos you
want jeff bezos's interviews
many of them people may say he's boring
right oh my gosh she's so boring to
listen to his interview
and here's also a guy that's built a
company that has turned into a
behemoth of a company based on
repetitively doing the same thing over
and over and over and over and over
again
but they have mastered the system and
they're not bored to do the same thing
over and over and over again because
if you get too creative with the system
you may lose your business
but he may be boring as an individual
and it doesn't serve him on camera now
watch another one here
elon musk you ever seen an interview
with elon musk he says the most random
things
i'd like to die on mars just not on
collision what do you mean
he wants to live there and die on now
who says things like this right you're
going to die on mars
if you look at people on uh a social or
a tv you know or presidency trump
very entertaining he ain't boring right
biden
boring okay hillary clinton boring
bill clinton not boring gw george bush
not boring he's funny right well you
know uh you you ever hear that thing
that says
you know if they go in you know what i'm
saying you know
wait a minute this guy is hilarious but
his father may be boring
jeb bush boring this is not political
obama not boring
this has nothing to do with your
political beliefs
this has to do with how you present
yourself if you're in the business of
getting
getting attention sales negotiation
interviewing writing you know podcast
whatever you do do not be boring now let
me kind of take this a little bit deeper
with you and hopefully this will make
sense you may say pat
what do i do to not be boring well think
about the next time
you're watching somebody speak and
immediately you change it why did you
change it
what caused you to be bored okay what
all of a sudden got you to say
i'm not interested in this person listen
to different people's styles and say
why does rogan interest me why do i like
listening to tucker carlson
why do i like jon stewart why are these
people funny to me
why am i not turned on by an anderson
cooper maybe
why am i not turned on by a rachel
maddow why am i not turned on by a
whoever may be on
why am i not turned on by some of these
guys because
the audience is wanting to be
entertained while you're delivering the
message that's the whole reason why we
call this channel valuetainment because
the hardest message to deliver online is
what
value education people don't go on
youtube to watch
value in educational videos people go on
youtube to watch entertaining videos
music cat videos comedy pranks
they watch these types of things they
don't go on there to say seven keys to
this
you can't teach people things if you're
not entertaining you have to figure out
a way to constantly add that spice
of being entertaining how can you be
entertaining if you're interviewing
somebody or sitting down with somebody
you go on a date
ask inquisitive questions don't ask the
boring questions
what are the three keys to success ask
some questions that people have been
asked before you know if you you know
that guy asked me something i didn't
think about yesterday i'm interviewing a
guy
who wrote a book called harbinger by the
end of the interview
he was flabbergasted he's like you know
you kind of
took me by surprise no one's ever asked
me those three questions before
and he's like so can you again send me
some stuff i don't know who you are
can you so i mean this is but you're
remembering and you walk in and say i
want to come back and
i want to have this conversation i had
you know me park here yesterday
who lived in north korea she's a
defector only 200 on us that are
defectors
you know why she's here yesterday
because she's not boring i'm sitting
listening to this person delivered their
message
it's not boring so again going back to
you
if you're watching the same path i have
no desire to create content
i have no desire to create anything
writing audio nothing
then don't worry about it but if you are
selling
if you are leading if you are
negotiating if you are doing any of that
stuff
you have to figure out a way to be
charismatic i ca i can tell you behind
closed doors
there's a bone of charisma with a bezos
you ever seen bezos laugh it's weird on
tv he may be boring
have you ever seen the way this guy
laughs it is the most unique
laugh that he has and again if you want
to build a big business if you want to
build anything that scales
you got to figure out a way to keep
people's attentions and that one way is
to not be boring there's many ways to go
about not being boring
a boring person only talks about
themselves you haven't seen these dates
that has
a boyfriend and girlfriend they go on or
blind they go on and you see the
guy just saying well let me take on my
job let me tell you how successful i'm
let me tell you about what i'm doing let
me tell you about this let me tell you
about that let me tell you who i am
and you just see the girls like and
she's texting somebody her friend i
can't wait to leave and she says oh you
know what
i'm going to go use the restroom she
didn't go use the restroom she just left
because she can't sit there and listen
to this guy more a charismatic
entertaining person is going to say so
tell me oh wow how about this oh
interesting
they're talking they're talking they're
talking they're talking
you become memorable when they walk away
say i really like how great of a
listener this person was
a quality of somebody who has a lot of
charisma they're great listeners
charismatic people are listeners it's
not that they talk non-stop
they're great listeners one way you can
do it is by being a great listener and
asking good questions people remember
you
for doing things like that so look you
may not have the personality of obama
you may not have the personality of
trump or tucker
or jon stewart or fallon or any of these
guys
what you can do is you can figure out a
way to use your own personality
to be memorable and do whatever you can
but be boring having said that i did a
video a couple years ago at ohika castle
in new york
in a room that was a charlie chaplin
room and i decided a video in this room
11 qualities of childlike that you can
be as an entrepreneur if you've never
seen this video before
i highly recommend you watch us click
over here to watch that and if you're
not subscribed to the channel please do
so
have a great week everybody take care
bye